what are you bumblebee
do you even know in his original 1980s
incarnation the transformer bumblebee
was a VW beetle a tiny toy light car
that kids could relate to because he
himself was like a kid brother to the
other Autobots he also had a young human
sounding voice that was perfect for
delivering stay in school bro life and
remember running away leads nowhere
but in the movies he like every other
element of transformer dem has been
turned up to 11 bumblebee is now a
strong silent muscle car a Camaro that
helps his human pal attract gals Michael
Bey says he gave bumblebee an amped-up
makeover because VW beetles make him
think of Herbie the lovebug
well listen you vacuous explosion monger
bumblebee is supposed to be a lovable
mascot also it's kind of disgusting how
movie bumblebee seems to want teenage
humans to make out inside of him and on
top of him
oh but for once Michael Bay is not the
ultimate source of evil for once
Hasbro and Tocker a muddy bumblebees
identity long before the live-action
movies began you see Autobots generally
stick to a single type of vehicle
Optimus Prime is almost always a truck
ratchet is some kind of ambulance jazz
is some kind of sports car but bumblebee
has been every sort of vehicle short of
a samboni
they turned him from a VW Beetle into a
Suzuki Swift unconscionable but hey at
least that's still a subcompact then he
was a sports car a station wagon
a muscle car bumblebee isn't a robot in
disguise he's a robot suffering from
acute dissociative brand identity
disorder how am I supposed to relate to
look there's nothing wrong with
exploring new identities but with no
stable vehicular incarnation bumblebee
calls into question the carefully
maintained logic of the entire
transformers universe I think he needs
to travel to the planet psychiatry and
schedule frights weekly sessions with
the esteemed therapy BOTS known as alpha
cortex ultra Freud he transforms into a
couch bumblebee can gradually merge his
dissociated personalities tarts
analogies until the one true self
emerges because you're not allowed to be
a robot made of a bunch of different
kinds of vehicles I mean what is this
Voltron what's next bumblebee the Pinto
what make and model would you like to
see tell me in the comments and
subscribe to the wire